you know it's gift giving season and you
know who's working their tails off to
make your holiday dreams come true our
nation's delivery workers
that's right
drivers from amazon usps fedex ups we
thank you and yahoo's report
that it's a really good thing
to say thanks by leaving a kind note or
a little treat outside your door
deliverers actually say that it gives
them a little boost when people share
water a gatorade snacks
cocoa
hand warmers a handwritten note anything
especially when they're in the colder
states totally
another hot tip is to leave your porch
lights on driver shifts are long and
some of the deliveries are going after
dark so if you want to be
environmentally sensitive maybe around
midnight i don't know whatever but i
just think this was really good
information
yeah and you know the world has changed
we're getting everything christmas gifts
everything we're ordering online they've
got to be delivered and i'm a talker you
know i like to say hi to them so my gift
to all of you is that i'm going to shut
up all right
because i know you got places to go and
things to do so thanks thank you don't
do that around here i i need you oh i'm
not gonna shut up around don't you dare
well you know we are all in the holiday
mood happy hanukkah to everybody
and we hope you're celebrating with
loved ones and latkes as far as the eye
can see but that's not all we have to
celebrate it's time for a segment we
like to call well every day is a holiday
[Applause]
yes it is we want to make sure you don't
miss out on some of the lesser-known
holidays and did you know today is a
holiday every day is a holiday well
that's the whole point right it's today
rossi today this is true is
make a gift day oh yeah a day to
celebrate a simpler tradition instead of
buying something extravagant if you can
just make something for someone you love
and so you know what i did drew what
i made you something you did
what is your favorite food of all time
macaroni and cheese macaroni and cheese
it is uh-huh and what i have made for
you is are you ready for the unveiling
this is a macaroni and cheese cream
there you go okay
yes
this is the raddest thing i've ever seen
and it also makes me i just want to lick
it
the frame yeah well i have burns from
the glue gun on my hands so thank you so
much you're welcome this is
incredible not bad right if you ever
really did produce this i feel like
people would buy this that frame yes
this is amazing well you know how much
joy this is gonna give me in my life i
mean where you put it like bedroom
living room where
i was gonna put it
here okay like or yeah i was going to
put it upstairs because we spend as much
time here as we do at home oh that's
true i like it right there
i love this so
that is the most thoughtful gift well i
did get a little something for you too
no you did not
what is this
i don't think it touches yours hold on
it is good i like it but this is no do
you know this is exactly what i wanted
she gave me a pass look tickets a pass
on eating one food item at the drew's
news desk
[Applause]
oh
i can if you look at this one i can wear
sweatpants to work day how about that
which i don't know if you're gonna be
into i'll give that one to you this one
is
drew gives ross a five minute massage
this is i didn't even know this is
possible you guys i'm sorry this is
prayers are answered okay
drew watches an episode of 90 day fiance
i know it's your favorite
and you know i've never seen a second of
it
drew i could cry you really know me i do
i knew exactly what i wanted thank you
so much
[Applause]
i'm gonna do it too
oh my god wow
so many in here oh i will
say that made gifts are some of the best
gifts for sure it's just that one
treasure that there's one of a kind and
it was made just for you by someone else
so
i say go for it this is a great day to
sell it i think so too
[Music]